over nine seasons in the NFL linebacker
Sam acho gained a reputation as a
physical Defender and a locker room
Mentor I'd love that but it is off the
field where he's made his biggest impact
outro was twice nominated for the Walter
Payton Man of the Year award for his
service in the Chicago Community as well
as in his parents home country of
Nigeria he has continued that work since
retirement and now serves as an
ambassador for the international Justice
Mission his new book is change starts
with you following your fire to heal a
broken World it aims to help readers
achieve their dreams and make the world
a better place samacho welcome it's so
good to see you it's good to see you as
well so excited about your book now you
call this not a how-to book but a let's
do book what does that mean well so so
many people write books and it's like
hey this is how you do this or how you
do that but my book is really an idea of
like how do we do this together the
change we want to make in the world
whether it's in our families in our
communities in our cities or even in
ourselves how do we do that together and
so this book really helps guide me and
others of how to make a change in the
world because it's so often like we all
want to do more but you don't really
know where to start yeah and obviously
the title has changed starts with you
but you really give tangible
um uh guidelines for how people can just
take small steps to find that mission
and kind of not make it so overwhelming
to give back yeah I played nine years in
the NFL and I had a football coach who
said once that little things done well
make big things happen talk about little
things done well make big things happen
and so often we think that we want to
make these huge strides and make these
major changes but we don't know where to
start and sometimes all you have to do
is start with the little things the
people in front of you to your left or
to your right maybe those issues that
are on your heart the things that are
really like making you angry or sad or
bringing you a little bit of pain what
if you address those things and then
address those issues in your own heart
and then watch the healing begin and so
those little things that you can focus
on I think if they can make a huge huge
change speaking of other football
references uh points of advice uh that
you say help off the field one of your
other quotes is eyes take your hands
hands take your feet what do you say in
there well in football sense we always
talk about what you focus on right if
you see a lot they say you see a lot you
see too much you don't see anything but
if you see a little you see a lot right
so if you focus on one thing let's say
for me it's like I want to make a change
in the city of Chicago where I played
where I lived and where I where I worked
it's not about this huge world no like
there's one person in one city there's a
young girl named nazaria who I became a
really great friend with 15 year old
girl who we worked together we actually
made a huge change in our community
because of that one conversation I
showed up week after week after week she
showed up week after week after week and
so all of a sudden this one little thing
my eyes focusing on this one person this
one issue it took my hands now let's
have a conversation then my feet
followed and so in football we say eyes
take your hands hands take your feet but
it also applies in life well I mean this
is going to be an all Quote based
interview
[Laughter]
is a big part of your life Faith is part
of the book uh and about Midway through
you have a line uh God can out dream you
what do you mean by that
so I'm a follower of Jesus and I'm a man
of faith and
we think about dreams and oftentimes we
think that well I'll never accomplish
that and it's too big or too grandiose
or it'll never be done and I feel like
God's saying no just watch like I want
you to dream but just watch people talk
about faith without works is dead so
believe but also like go and do and move
and act don't just believe and sit down
and like I hope it's gonna happen no I
have a dream like I gave you a dream
Follow That Dream Act on that dream and
watch people join you and that's the
thing we talk about even in this book I
talk about this idea of like I didn't
know we were going to make this huge
change in Chicago there was just just
passion inside of me and all of a sudden
people started coming and so it was a
bigger dream that I couldn't have could
have imagined but God out dreams every
single one of us we could all probably
look at our examples in our lives we
never thought we'd be here and there's
more to come yeah and saying it out loud
too huge yeah you were taking us to
church
um so you and I have met before because
we did a story together a more perfect
union for CBS mornings about your work
in Chicago tell us about the work what
inspired it and what you guys did so I
played for the Chicago Bears for four
years and I always wanted to go to a
place where I could make an impact in my
community in my city in the place where
I lived and where I worked and I saw
something it was right around covid when
George Floyd was killed and he turned on
the TV and it's looting and it's riding
and it's chaos and I decided to get some
teammates and some friends together and
just check it out like let's see what's
going on and first we listened to some
kids in the community some police
officers some athletes but also we took
a tour of the west side of Chicago and
on our tour we saw a food desert yes we
saw you know buildings boarded up in
broken glass we saw this place that was
no healthy food no food at all there
were two grocery stores and 17 liquor
stores and a half mile radius and so
little old me I'm thinking I'm an
athlete I don't I like to eat food I
don't know much about like building
restaurants and stuff but some young
entrepreneurs we call them came together
and said what if we could tear down one
of the liquor stores and turn it into a
food mart so that's what we got a chance
to do and it's funny when we connected
that was right at the very beginning
stages of this idea and now a few years
later it's become this full-blown now
it's a pop-up Mark but it's turning into
a permanent food market and look at that
it's gorgeous yeah yeah it's it's just
been it's
yeah it's been unbelievable it's been
unbelievable speaking of unbelievable uh
by one estimate there is a .023 chance
of Any Given youth football player
making to the NFL and you've got two NFL
players from your family so what's going
on I'm talking about your brother
Emmanuel show yeah so our parents
obviously did a great job my mom and dad
were both born and raised in Nigeria so
when they hear football they think
soccer right right but there was an
opportunity and obviously we were
education was huge for us and our family
but all of a sudden we my brother and I
went to this football camp at USC back
in 05 and 06 and they were at this
National Powerhouse and got discovered
and all of a sudden I got scholarships
from all these different schools right
God cannot dream you I did not plan on
going to play football in college let
alone professionally we'll fast forward
nine years later I played four years in
college went to a national championship
played a nine-year NFL career but one
thing I realized is that that was just
the beginning my real passion and real
purpose is starting now it's in changing
the world changing people's eyes their
minds their hearts and also changing
mine as well I love that because making
it to the NFL is the end goal for so
many people and you're saying that was
just the beginning that was the the
Preamble yeah thank you so so much for
joining us the book is change starts
with you and it is on sale now